all right mom we've done it we got it
great
well taught well taught i have a good
teacher hi guys i'm matt welcome back to
my kitchen and it is hanukkah one of my
favorite holidays and the time of year
where i get to enjoy one of my favorite
foods potato latkes they're crunchy on
the outside they're fluffy on the inside
you can enjoy them with sour cream with
applesauce whatever you want i love them
so much unfortunately i am not able to
go home and be with my family for the
holidays this year so in order to
satisfy my craving for homemade latkes i
am joined by none other than my own mom
hi everyone i'm laura i'm matt's mom i'm
here to teach him how to make vodkas the
way my grandmother and my mother did all
right mom are you excited are you ready
i am so ready
awesome let's do it
[Music]
mom i am ready you had me peel the
potatoes so i'm assuming we move on to
shredding this is the dangerous part
okay how often did grandma make these
growing up
and then would you help her growing up
or would she just do it on her own my
grandmother it on her own
but my mother would
get grandpa to be the greatest grandpa
doesn't cook that often though grandpa
doesn't [ __ ] at all
he's tried over the years he used to say
that it wasn't complete unless there was
a little bit of knuckle oh god i
wouldn't eat some of the potato at the
risk of cutting it
oh what you okay yeah no i'm good see
look i saved a little bit which
grandmother did latkes uh they both did
lashes but i remember my father's mother
doing it more he would have enjoyed her
cooking he would have enjoyed both their
folks because they were both very good
you can see them starting from brown
oh yeah they're oxidizing a little bit
right yeah but that's okay okay i think
i'm only going to use a half an onion
for this and do i just shred it like i
shred the potato you want to do it a
little bit finer
okay they don't cook very long so you
want to make sure that you don't have
chunks of onion
so the finer's better okay
this is quite the workout it is and he
may tear up how your eyes doing getting
a little eerie okay
matthew oh huh i do miss you i miss you
too
make sure you wipe the inside and get
all the onion and potatoes that hang out
on the inside
oh yeah look at that all this pulp
inside now was making latkes a big deal
in your house growing up it wasn't a big
deal but nobody ever really followed a
recipe it's got very few ingredients
so what we need to do next is
i'm using a
nut milk bag okay you can use a towel or
you can use a pillowcase and
i'm just going to take the onions and
the potatoes and put them in the nut
milk bag and then squeeze out the liquid
got it oh wow it's already it's already
dripping
oh whoa
okay
that's a lot of liquid
wow just when you think you've gotten it
all out it still keeps going
i mean you're not going to be able to
get all the water out but right here's a
lot
i think i've gotten most of it out
that's good now you can set it aside
okay and i can just throw this away
don't say that
if you look carefully you'll see the
white potato starch settled on the
bottom oh yeah all through there
carefully bring off the liquid oh yeah
okay like that yeah perfect and just set
this aside yep now it's time to mix them
so you have to empty your towel or
whatever you're using reverse my nut sac
i don't think you'd say that
oh wow this is pretty dry yeah no this
is really dry add the potato starch and
start off with one egg because you don't
you don't want it too much moisture they
don't crisp ah got it add a little bit
of salt a little bit of pepper
mix it together
my family didn't really eat the recipe
so we may need to add the extra egg
and i'm thinking we might i'm going to
add the second egg traditionally you'll
add another binder you'll add bottom
yellow or lots
just to pull it all together and let it
hold its shape i would start like a
tablespoon at a time looks like a
tablespoon ish
you just want it to kind of hold its
shape a little bit got it i'm going to
add a little bit more just because i
feel like it needs it and don't worry
about seasoning or if you need more of a
binder we're going to test this i'd say
my mixture looks pretty good or is that
it that's it
so now we're ready to cook the latkes
and you need about a quarter of an inch
of a neutral oil i'm using grapeseed oil
today
medium heat medium high so give it a
stir at some point it separates oh yeah
mine did separate that's one okay very
carefully
and then i'm smooshing it down and i'm
just going to let this go and check it
in about two minutes i think i'm going
to flip mine i think mine's ready fine
all right
ready
oh wow
oh that looks good
yeah the comments will tell me if it
looks good or bad so
you want to make sure they're cooked
enough so that the potato cooks through
all right i'm actually happy with this
i'm going to pull mine can you see that
it looks good all right i'm going to
transfer to a rack
i'm gonna try it
i might add a little more salt oh it's
all steamy on the inside look at that
[Music]
cool and i'm just adding a little bit of
salt to mine once you know that the
boxes are seated properly you can just
cook the rest of them all right so we're
just going to fry the rest of our latkes
and then check back in and see how i did
all right i'm pulling my last one off
and ba-boom
all right mom we've done it we've done
it how's it come out matt mine mine look
great you want to take a look
great
i prefer my latkes with applesauce and
sour cream you prefer differently though
i do i prefer
sour cream only no applesauce to each
his own you ready to dig in ready let's
do it
it's crisp and lacy on the outside and
it's nice and soft and like fluffy on
the inside nice soft well taught well
taught i have a good teacher it's passed
down from generation to generation and
everybody adds their own flair to it so
it's everybody's blossom mom thank you
so much for showing me how to do this
thank you for letting me teach you how
to do this and wish you were home but
this was nice let's do it again let's do
it again i hope you enjoyed the video
please let us know what you think in the
comments below or you can message me on
instagram i wish everyone a happy
holiday and bye
oh yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you